l'éthique à présent les réunions
publiques pour les candidats de la
primaire à droite et du son qui vont se
dérouler en novembre 2016 se multiplient
hier mercredi soir c'était au tour du
comité de soutien d'un juppé de se
réunir à versailles une réunion animée
par fabienne keller sénatrice du bas du
bas rhin et porte parole du candidat
il était question a des impacts d'un
éventuel abric site des nouvelles
politiques énergétiques mais également
des nouvelles formes de mobilité
écoutez là elle était au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude à la
politique énergétique comme la mobilité
c'est le concept d'une société plus
sobre
alain juppé s'est beaucoup engagé sur
ces thématiques environnementales de
transport bien sûr comme maire de
bordeaux donc c'est une politique
d'ensemble que nous sommes en train de
construire est ce qui est passionnant
c'est que dans les réunions beaucoup de
concitoyens ont une contribution très
concrète et c'est ainsi que nous sommes
en train de contenus constituer ce les
principales propositions qui seront
publiées dans les prochaines semaines